und jetzt ist es tatsächlich passiert
nach dem wahlchaos hier in berlin sie
erinnern sich zu wenig stimmzettel ewig
lange schlangen menschen die nicht
wählen konnten jetzt die quittung die
landeswahlleitung will beim berliner
verfassungsgericht einspruch gegen die
ergebnisse der wahl zum abgeordnetenhaus
hier in berlin am 26 september einlegen
ja das also die breaking news hierbei
bild live darüber wollen wir sprechen
auch mit bild chef julian reichelt also
mit einigen worten zusammengefasst es
ist ziemlich schief gelaufen bei der
wahl hier in berlin und jetzt haben die
behörden auch selbst kapiert bei der
wahl hier in berlin ist so ziemlich
alles schiefgelaufen was irgendwie
schief laufen konnte es ist ja
eigentlich nicht so schwierig eine wahl
zu organisieren das funktioniert überall
in deutschland
flüssig und ohne jegliche probleme nur
hier in berlin unsere zuschauer werden
sich erinnern wir haben gross damals
darüber berichtet zu wenig stimmzettel
in den wahllokalen lange schlangen davor
die wahl musste verlängert werden dann
war unklar für wen darf man jetzt noch
wählen fürs berliner abgeordnetenhaus
oder auch noch für die bundes für den
bundestag nach 18 uhr das ist bis heute
nicht so wirklich geklärt wer da noch
wann eigentlich für was wählen durfte
und jetzt ist es zu dem ergebnis
gekommen zudem es zwingend kommen musste
die landeswahlleitung lustigerweise
unter der führung einer bereits
abberufen landeswahlleiterin auch das
gibt es nur in berlin legt einspruch
beim berliner verfassungsgericht 1 gegen
das ergebnis dieser wahl und das kann
tatsächlich heißt dass die damit die wir
gerade sehen franziska gefällt die
wahlsiegerin von der spd vielleicht
jetzt doch nicht die wahlsiegerin ist
weil die wahl wiederholt werden muss
jeder der dieses chaos miterlebt hat
kann nur zwingend zu dem schluss kommt
dass diese wahl natürlich wiederholt
werden muss es gab so groteske
abweichungen es kam so groteske
unregelmäßigkeiten es gab in bezirke mit
wahlbeteiligung von 850 prozent davon
hätte erich honecker geträumt von
solcher wahlbeteiligung dann hätte er
nämlich auch 150% endlich der stimmen
bekommen können all das gibt es nur in
berlin all das geht jetzt zum glück vor
gericht und man kann nur hoffen dass das
zu dem einzig richtigen ergebnis wird
nämlich dass diese wahl der schande
wiederholt wird und dass jeder mensch in
dieser stadt der zur wahl gehen will
auch die möglichkeit bekommt eben zu
weit zu gehen und seine stimme ab denn
das hatten viele menschen an diesem
unseligen wahlsonntag hier in berlin
nicht dass er aus wie in caracas und
nicht wie in berlin erinnern sie standen
hier im studio auch mit menschen die uns
darüber berichtet haben die wahlzettel
dennoch irgendwie spontan per fahrrad
organisiert wurden und dann springt sagt
jemand auch es geht gleich weiter es
wird sogar überhaupt gar nicht wie eine
wahl und viele sind eben auch wieder
umgekehrt vor allem ältere vor allem
familien mit kindern die gesagt haben ja
wir können jetzt nicht stundenlang
ausharren bis wieder genug wahlzettel da
sind jetzt haben wir ja aus dieser
erfahrung gesehen es kann manchmal
dauert es geht manchmal so unfassbar
schief was bedeutet jetzt das jetzt hier
auch für die wählerinnen und wähler in
berlin rechnest du damit dass jetzt
relativ schnell eine entscheidung fallen
wird ist ein neues datum geben wird und
dann wird wieder gewählt oder ist auch
dass wieder ein prozessor wir sagen
müssen der markt erstmal geht es jetzt
zum berliner verfassungsgericht und das
muss darüber entscheiden das kann
natürlich auch theoretisch sagen ja
waren gar nicht so viele wähler ist
nicht so wichtig ich glaube nicht dass
es das sagen wenn ich glaube es wird
entscheiden dass diese wahl so keine
gültigkeit hat der entscheidende punkt
ist die unregelmäßigkeiten könnten
auswirkungen haben auf die
sitzverteilung im abgeordnetenhaus das
heißt dann einer weniger von denen und
einer mehr von denen weil die ware nicht
richtig gelaufen ist und das ist sicher
nicht der sinn der demokratie die wenn
man so will gute nachricht ist dass wir
in den letzten stunden ja erfahren haben
dass franziska giffey die horror
regierung dieser stadt die regierung die
diese stadt in ein failed state
verwandelt hat in ein moloch in dem
nichts mehr funktioniert die sicherheit
nicht funktioniert der flughafen nicht
funktioniert wo man vier stunden vor
abflug da sein muss um einen inlandsflug
nach münchen zu bekommen ganz kurz das
rechenbeispiel eine stunde aus der stadt
zum flughafen vier stunden vorher da
eine stunde flug nach münchen eine
stunde in die stadt nach münchen sind
sieben stunden um von der berliner
innenstadt in die münchner innenstadt
mit dem flugzeug gekommen waren dauert
ungefähr vier stunden 20 diese horror
regierung will sich jetzt wieder zur
regierung aufschwingen in berlin obwohl
es eine bürgerliche eine ampelkoalition
zb möglich wäre will man wieder sagen
mit den menschen die wenige meter von
hier an der mauer auf menschen schießen
das mit den nachfolgern dieser partei
mit der linkspartei machen wir wieder
dieselbe caracas chaos failed state
regierung das hat franziska gipfel unter
großem druck der berliner partei vor
wenigen stunden bekannt gegeben eine
absolute horror entscheidung und
vielleicht haben wir glück und können
tatsächlich noch mal wählen und
vielleicht können einige berliner sagen
dass sie mit dieser horror entscheidung
den daad franziska gefällt ihr wahres
gesicht gezeigt jeder weiß sie wollte
diese koalition nicht jetzt hat sie sich
da rein pressen lassen das könnte für
sie absolut verheerend enden denn
franziska gegen all ihre versprechen hat
deutlich gemacht doch gerne mit den sed
und mauerschützen nachfolgern möchte ich
weiter berlin auf diese chaotische weise
regieren wir haben eine kleine chance
darauf dass uns das wahlchaos davor
bewahrt also die politik die dieses
chaos hier in der stadt in den
vergangenen jahren ganz wesentlich
angerichtet hat und jetzt auch am
heutigen tag durch diesen einspruch der
landeswahlleiterin eingesteht die fühlt
sich gerade in ihrer arbeit heute an
diesem tag noch zusätzlich bestätigt
kann es passieren julian dass franziska
giffey mit ihrer neuen rot rot roten
regierung dann vereidigt ist und dann
danach erst bekannt gegeben wird gilt
alles nicht das ist mit sicherheit alles
möglich aber man kann dann nur darauf
hoffen dass der rechtsstaat das zeigt
was er ist nämlich die letzte instanz
des rechts und nicht des unrechts und
egal wer dann schon die hand zum eid
gehoben hat dass das dann eben nicht
mehr zählt denn bei einer wahl gilt und
das ist das konzept der weil jeder muss
wählen können wenn er wählen will wenn
er wahlberechtigt ist das ist ein recht
zu wählen und die leute die wir wählen
sind nicht unsere herrscher sondern
unsere angestellten und wenn sie auf
legitime weise an die macht gekommen
sind dann muss ihnen diese macht wieder
genommen werden hier sehen wir die
langen schlangen davor vor den
wahllokalen wirklich unglaubliche szenen
damals hier in der hauptstadt man hat
das wirklich nicht für möglich gehalten
menschen die versuchen wählen zu gehen
die teilweise wieder umgedreht sind oder
stundenlang ausharren so sieht es sonst
nur am berliner flughafen aus
[Musik]